Any 90s rom-com connoisseur
knows all about
She's All That.
Well, now we've welcomed
its 2021
gender-swapped reimagining,
He's All That, to Netflix,
starring none other
than Addison Rae
in her debut role.
Let's dive in
to the most
searched questions
about He's All That.
I will create
the next prom king.
As we mentioned,
He's All That is a remake
of 90s rom-com classic,
She's All That.
In the original,
Freddie Prinze Jr's
popular jock, Zach,
is challenged to turn
artsy outsider, Laney Boggs,
played
by Rachael Leigh Cook,
into the most popular girl
in school.
The original film
boasted an impressive cast
of up-and-coming actors
of the time.
You've got Usher,
Kieran Culkin,
and eventual Oscar Winner,
Anna Paquin.
Laney Boggs,
get your cute butt
down here.
Not to mention,
this was Gabrielle Union's
debut film.
Oh, gracias, pappi.
But did you know,
the 90s film
was the modern adaptation
of George Bernard Shaw's
play Pygmalion
and its 1964 film
counterpart, My Fair Lady.
The latter, of course, being
one of Audrey Hepburn's
most well-known roles.
How do you do?
While each of those versions
of the story
featured a young woman
being made over,
He's All That
switches the script.
This time,
a social media influencer
is trying to turn
the least popular guy
in school
into prom king.
And suitably,
that social media influencer
is played by none other
than Addison Rae,
one of Tik Tok's
biggest stars.
Addison
plays Padgett Sawyer,
a girl who livestreams
every aspect of her life,
unfortunately including
an embarrassing breakup
when she catches
her boyfriend cheating.
You know what?
You don't deserve me!
You don't deserve my love
and you don't deserve
my croquembouche
-you croquem-douche!
-Padgett!
What?
You're still live.
She tries to rescue
her reputation
by accepting a bet
to make-over
the least popular boy
in school.
Don't think I can do it?
This is Addison's
first acting role
and told Variety
she started
crying hysterically
when she was offered
the job.
Starring opposite Addison
as the 2021 version
of Laney Boggs,
this time
a moody photographer
named Cameron Kweller,
is Tanner Buchanan.
You can't enjoy this
without sharing it
with 500 strangers?
500? Try 887,132.
And we're not strangers,
they're followers.
Followers?
You mean like a cult?
You may well recognise him
from Netflix's Cobra Kai,
in which he plays
Johnny Lawrence's son,
Robby Keene.
Also appearing
is The Game Plan's
Madison Pettis
as Alden,
Peyton Meyer
of Girl Meets World fame,
as cheating ex
Jordan van Draanen,
and singer-songwriter
Myra Molloy as Quinn.
You're gonna create another
internationally-renowned
egomaniac?
Your eyes
weren't deceiving you
when the trailer dropped.
That is the one and only
Kourtney Kardashian.
She plays Padgett's agent,
Jessica Miles Torres.
I am your biggest supporter.
No one has more faith in you
than I do,
but until
you turn things around,
don't talk to me.
Kourtney and Adison
have been friends
for a while now,
appearing on each other's
social media regularly.
Adison told Access Hollywood
she suggested Kourtney
for the role,
as someone
who had been important
to her own journey
into stardom.
-Love ya.
There was some speculation
the characters in the 2021
film were related
to the ones
from the 90s film,
but that's not the case.
This is
a reimagining of the story,
but with
different characters.
He's All That
does have some nods
to the original film,
including a prom dance-off,
and some familiar dialogue.
-I was a bet?
-No.
No, I was a fucking bet.
Am I a bet?
Am I a fucking bet?
On top of that,
two of the original
cast members return.
Rachel Leigh Cook
plays Padgett's mother,
dispatching sage advice
for the heartbroken teen...
Well, yeah, you screwed up,
but it's only a mistake
if you don't learn from it.
...and the one and only
Matthew Lillard,
who played reality TV star
Brock Hudson
in She's All That,
returns
as the school principal.
We have some
weird-ass traditions
at this school.
Though,
that doesn't prevent him
from having a little dance.
The connections
to the original
don't finish there.
She's All That
was R. Lee Fleming Jr.'s
first film to hit screens
and he's returned
to write the script
for He's All That.
Joining him
behind the screen
is director Mark Waters,
who definitely
knows this genre very well,
having directed the iconic
Mean Girls.
That is so fetch.
To see how the reimagining
has turned out,
make sure you catch it
now streaming on Netflix.
And for more facts about new
and upcoming Netflix films,
make sure you subscribe
to the channel.
Why do I know this song?